bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros logran bagwell es presidente de
costa de marfil juzgado en países bajos
por crímenes de lesa humanidad regresó a
su país después de 10 años de su
extradición cuando la corte penal
internacional terminó por absorberlo su
retorno tiene dividida la nación miles
de simpatizantes le dieron la bienvenida
al controvertido ex mandatario todo un
recibimiento de héroe pero el regreso de
este político de 76 años no es bien
visto por todos sobre todo por aquellos
que padecieron el conflicto después de
las elecciones de 2010 y 2011 entre el
actual presidente alassane ouattara y
bach
lo que provocó al menos unos 3.000
muertos en un país sumido en
hostilidades ambos en ese entonces se
proclamaron vencedores ahora lo que
viene es el inicio de un verdadero
proceso de reconciliación esta es la
historia
[Música]
habían rotonda de agua para los
seguidores de laurent gbagbo han venido
en masa pero no son bienvenidos la crs
compañía republicanas de seguridad
tienen la orden de bloquear el acceso al
aeropuerto este jueves debería ser un
día de celebración pero hay mucho
descontento tratan de impedir nos lo
estamos tratando de venir para recibir a
nuestro presidente los embargo nos
disparan con balas reales pero usted
habla de reconciliación ellos hablan de
reconciliación no le puedes decir
reconciliación a alguien y luego
impedirle regresar o impedir que su
popularidad no reciba el siguiente punto
del programa parece fuerte
al mismo tiempo a siete mil kilómetros
de ahí el aeropuerto de bruselas lo
bomba o acaba de ser declarado inocente
de crímenes de lesa humanidad un hombre
libre después de siete años de cárcel en
la haya
cuando empezamos en ese concepto
cuando yo llegué a la corte penal
internacional tenía miedo pensé bueno
tal vez se hicieron cosas en mi nombre
que yo no sabía de su club
o como sea
pero cuando el fiscal y su gabinete
empezaron a rechazar todas las
acusaciones bueno sentí que no había
nada y después de ese momento a los que
iban a visitarme les dije que regresaría
la crisis postelectoral marfileña de
2011 dejó más de 3.000 muertos con
masacres en ambos bandos podrá costa de
márfil pasar la página embarque
inmediato hacia abiyán y desde ya un
sonido de fondo
dice no es tanto
[Música]
d
precisamente son fotos al isi
faltando unas horas para su regreso lo
gamba parece optimista su mayor triunfo
según el seguir siendo popular porque
viene del pueblo
edite de post política
yo no heredé un lugar político yo luché
[Aplausos]
me dice solo desde que era muy pequeño
[Música]
y
entonces cuando hablo del pueblo no son
palabras al aire
a mí
pronto aparece la laguna de abellán y
los barrios de la ciudad que tiene 5
millones de habitantes el plato chupón
abobo cocody x fue como así tres mil a
la llame y muchos otros el gobierno le
hizo a lo gone bad boy los honores del
pabellón presidencial pero ninguno de
los ministros de alassane outtara se
desplazó
a ver
a la salida del avión rápidamente se
forma una muchedumbre hasta tal punto
que el acompañante del logo macbook debe
alzar la voz
rodeado por sus seguidores el gran pacto
saluda al personal del aeropuerto
antes de partir en carro los jefes
tradicionales y los reyes de costa de
marfil deberán prescindir de los saludos
algunos hablan de sabotaje
el presidente bajo fue absuelto decidió
regresar a su país con una intervención
del presidente ouattara quien aceptó a
abrir el pabellón de honor quien aceptó
que su hermano llegara pero al parecer
yo tengo la impresión de que hay un
partido un clan que no desea la
reconciliación el cortejo del ex
presidente se adentra en la noche
algunos seguidores de bakwa expresan su
rabia contra occidente acusado de ser el
culpable de su caída
[Música]
esta canción
también tanto si me dices la contra
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en su cuartel general y luego un packbot
se encuentra con sus camaradas del fp y
frente popular marfileño su partido el
sonido no funciona muy bien pero que
cada uno recordará una frase
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy feliz de volver a estar en costa
de márfil y en áfrica
[Aplausos]
al día siguiente en el barrio de
yopougon seguro electoral del hogar 8
laurent para perduran como muestra la
reconciliación
alan pakula áfrica y del mapa
su regreso ya inspiró a los músicos
sordos pero para otros seguidores de la
banda por reunidos aquí en un ágora
participativa la fiesta se echó un poco
a perder según ellos el actual
presidente alassane quattara debería
haber recibido abajo en el aeropuerto y
la reconciliación debe ser sincera
uattara aceptó la reconciliación pero no
realmente dices que sólo hay que
reconciliarse es verdad no entonces si
vamos bien
debes estar en el aeropuerto debes
hacerle acababa mi hermano hagamos
borrón y cuenta nueva todo lo que pasó
lo dejamos atrás
cerca del aeropuerto algunos seguidores
de logan pacto terminaron su jornada en
una cama del hospital de port bouet
pierna esperaba ver a su campeón un
miembro de las fuerzas del orden se lo
impidió prefiere dar un testimonio
anónimo por temor a las represalias
iba en camino al aeropuerto para el
recibimiento de laurent gbagbo recibió
un lacrimógeno a la altura del todo y un
tiro de lacrimógeno como pasó eso
en realidad la persona estaba en frente
mío y me paró en el tobillo
quemarropa a la altura del tobillo y la
gran entidad y además tengo una fractura
en el hueso deben operar el origen de
todas esas tensiones entre el pueblo del
expresidente y del que está actualmente
en el poder la crisis de 2011 la
victoria de la sano a tara cerró el
debate durante 10 años pero el logan
bakú su rival sigue afirmando una
lectura de los eventos radicalmente
distinta
desciende
una tala uruguay
algunos decidieron poner aguantar en el
poder de nuestro golfo que la persona
pero para ponerlo en el poder es
necesario que lugar esté vacío
sacarme con él pero yo me considero como
el ganador de la elección presidencial
de 2010
eso es evidente
bueno vamos a retroceder el tiempo hasta
2010 no vamos a volver atrás para tener
una idea de la cantidad de violencia que
sufrieron algunos habitantes de abiyán
basta con regresar de nuevo a yopougon
aquí ellos sufres minoría este es un
seguidor de la sang hwa tara hace 10
años su familia fue víctima de una
redada mortal de las milicias pro gbagbo
y ouattara debían matarnos porque somos
militantes dental porque votamos por el
hermano mayor hermano menor primo todos
murieron de bala fueron ejecutados se lo
digo fueron ejecutados no ha visto una
verdadera justicia en la corte penal
internacional porque éramos víctimas
víctimas en todos los sentidos del
hombre en bakú
por su parte el logan packbot considera
que la justicia internacional lo
absolvió y que no es responsable por los
crímenes de 2011
algunas víctimas consideran que usted
tiene una responsabilidad tal vez moral
que le diría a esas víctimas no les digo
nada
me reuniré con ellas después pues yo
tengo mi agenda tengo mi agenda de
actividades me reuniré con los
representantes de las víctimas con los
que se organizaron pero dije que el
asunto fue juzgado cumplir diez años
regresó a mi casa absuelto pero también
es un hecho que se debe respetar
la crisis electoral de 2010 2011 sigue
envenenando a la sociedad marfileña
trabi valeria es periodista fue testigo
directo de esa época y ha investigado
las masacres en ambos bandos la crisis
poselectoral de 2010 contribuyó a
exacerbar los conflictos territoriales
los conflictos étnicos los conflictos
comunitarios y yo diría incluso
religiosos porque pastores e imanes que
fueron asesinados si las personas no
bajan su tono para pensar que costa de
márfil viene de lejos que pasamos por
una crisis donde hubo más de 3000
muertos si los discursos los mismos
discursos del pasado regresan volveremos
a caer erróneamente volveremos a caer en
lo mismo en las mismas conductas de
2010-2011
[Música]
actualmente el discurso en ambos bandos
es un llamado a la calma
la consigna reconciliación y en este
domingo el siguiente después de su
llegada la anpact lleva a cabo su primer
acto político conocido por ser miembro
de una pequeña iglesia evangelista viene
a visitar a los católicos y su viejo
amigo el cardenal cutura tiene una
sorpresa para ellos
le voy a pedir al presidente bajo que me
conceda el honor que en un momento dado
el presidente laurent se fue de la
iglesia para volverse después de ese
pequeño desvío por donde los evangélicos
pensó voy a regresar
[Aplausos]
es un país muy creyente demostrar la fe
es una virtud pues para los cercanos al
expresidente es momento de rehabilitar a
su campeón
el habitable esto significa el comienzo
de la verdadera reconstrucción pero
sobre todo significa el reconocimiento
de la verdad la verdad que había sido
escondida que había sido verdad de qué
está hablando señor de todo lo que pasó
quiero hablar sobre las acusaciones que
le hicieron que no eran ciertos que eran
totalmente falsas actualmente la corte
penal internacional los limpió y regresa
absuelto es people es una gran alegría
para los marfileños lo hagan packbot
sueña con encarnar la reconciliación
pero también el bando de todos los que
nos encuentran en la costa de márfil
actual
y muchos de sus seguidores desearían que
usted pudiera participar en 2025 para la
gran elección que hará en 2025
demande
sólo como parte no excluyo nada estoy en
la política le pedí a la dirección de mi
partido que me dejara hacer el duelo
sobre todo llorar a mi madre el cuidado
por el sí de un soldado
y bueno además soy un soldado
los observadores le atribuyen al actual
presidente alassane ouattara en la
intención de cambiar la constitución
para la elección de 2025 reduciría la
edad máxima de candidatura a 75 años
incluso a 70 años una manera de pasar la
página
excluyéndose y eliminando a sus rivales
henri konan bédié y logan pack book
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web trans 24
puntocom para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima acción
[Música]